Do you recommend any particular PEMF devices?
I have been using a small and expensive PEMF device called the Vibe, and it has helped
immensely with the panic attacks I've been applying to it.
Now, I'm thinking that maybe finding another device for breast cancer in Lyme disease would
be helpful for me specifically rather than just the rifling.
If you would like me to make an appointment to discuss this rather than zoom in, we'd be
happy to.
Well, first of all, PEMF devices are different because there are some devices that are
low-ghost devices, and that's what the Vibe is.
The Vibe is a low-demo-douse, PEMF device that's, you said, expensive, but the Vibe is relatively
inexpensive.
Maybe that's what you meant, but the problem is the higher-ghost machines are much more
expensive.
So you go up in price-based upon the ghost level.
So, like, our professional one that we have in the clinic is made by Pulse, and that
is about 30,000 ghosts, and they're about $40,000.
The Vibe is about $600, and they're about $600, and, you know, I know some of you have
a beaver at home.
The beaver is a device that's only about 1,000 ghosts.
Unfortunately, the reason why I don't like the beaver is I take their way over price for
the ghost level that output is because I think they're about $7,000.
So you really pay per ghost is what you pay for.
Now, is the higher ghosts always better?
Well, no, this is serally, it depends on what you're trying to use it for.
So really, the level of ghost output on a PEMF device really defines the benefits of that
device, and what you would use it for.
The reason why I got the high-ghost unit is because I was doing it for cancer-aligned patients
and you really want high-ghost output.
The low-ghost devices are not going to really be, you know, helpful for a cancer patient
deal.
They can help with some secondary effects, and, you know, they can actually help with vagal
stimulation.
And I think that's what you're getting is the vagal stimulation benefits of a low-ghost
unit.
And that's what's helping with your anxiety.
But it's not going to really regenerate organs.
It's not going to do some of the things that a high-ghost machine would do.
So, but they're really expensive.
So, you know, we have, you know, we do sell a machine that goes up to about, I think, $8,000
for the machine.
So, they get to be expensive.
I do have a used one right now if you're really interested, if this is something you're really
interested in.
So, definitely contact me.
I have actually used professional high-ghost machine that I'd be willing to part with.
It's a good machine, I actually use it as a whole.
But they're just they're pricey.
And if a person has got, you know, I have patients that just don't have financial issues.
And they're like, oh, buy this machine, oh, buy this machine, oh, buy this.
And they basically have more equipment in their house than I am in my office.
And that's great.
If you could do that, I think we're moving into a time where it's very difficult to trust
any practitioners.
And if you have the money to have devices in your house, that's great.
But everybody could do that.
And I get it.
So, then what do you do?
Your triums.
What's the most important thing if you have cancer?
All right, machine.
And then you go, what's the second most important?
Well, it depends on what type of cancer you have.
You have brain cancer that I'd get a H bomb machine.
So, it, you just kind of go through that list of, you know, what would be the most important devices.
You have, you know, hyperthermia, P-E-F, H-Bot, you know, different, different things like that.
You kind of go through what would be, you know, depends on your budget.
So, yes, you could call and make it a play with me.
And I'll gladly discuss that with you.